I'm just saying milk does the booty good
really cuz I got a good booty oh what
the I was just about to smash -
y'all do some DeVry hi better stop
taking all our beats what can I say it's
it was loved wrong humps a mere
of wrong
hey fellas it's election season I hope I
can count on your vote no last time
I voted Fantasia lost we'll all righty
what kind of lame would want to run for
class president you know he don't get no
ass hey craigory love your feminist
platform it would be so awesome to have
a women's history class I think we need
women's Lit feminist science and clamp
clitoris Awareness Month
I'd love to hear more we should do lunch
yo hammy you need to make a move
president skidmark about to beat you to
standees ballot box excuse me everybody
I'd like to announce my candidacy for
student body president vote for me for a
chain I see they love me your boys gonna
be President real soon